Please welcome the queens of The Home Edit,
and my dear friends, Clea Shearer and Joanna Teplin.
Oh, thank you so much.
(women exclaiming)
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
In honor of our collaboration,
and our blossoming friendship, which I'm so grateful for,
you guys are gonna give us three spring cleaning tips
for three different rooms in your house.
And first up, I think you guys have the bedroom.
Yes.
So take it away.
Okay, we're gonna show you how to fold.
It is a very common thing that people,
my daughter for instance, is terrible at it.
This is her idea of folding.
And it's a lot of people's idea of folding.
So what you wanna do is you wanna start,
put the shirt face down, and then it's really simple.
It's a file folding method
so that you can see every single thing that you have.
And you just, instead of a pile
where you can't see anything underneath.
That's right.
So you just fold it like this.
And then what you wanna do is a tri-fold.
You bring it up, and then you bring it up like that.
The tri-fold, that's the difference.
And if you want, by the way,
if you have a drawer that can, you can like this.
That's my favorite part. It's very satisfying.
You can do a tuck, and you just basically, you know,
you put it right in just like that.
And Joanna, if you wanna put the, like Vanna White here.
This is a drawer divider, which is so helpful
as far as keeping items in place
without them moving too much.
So after you, say you have all your short sleeve t-shirts,
you could then add the drawer divider,
and just lock it into place,
and then have all, say, your long sleeve t-shirts here.
So then you always know, when you open the drawer,
exactly what you have.
And actually, I think one of these drawers is already,
here we go.
Ah!
So this is what it looks like all nicely folded.
(audience applauds)
And it's so easy, honestly, it's so easy.
(Drew shrieks in excitement)
I know, and you can see everything
without having to pull from the middle of a stack
and everything falls over.
Great.
And of course, we like to rainbow-ify everything,
if possible, so a little ROYGBIV never hurt anyone.
And you can find exactly what you're looking for.
Oh, I need a blue shirt today,
well guess what, it's in the blue section.
Right, and your whole drawer then stays in place
as opposed to just all this.
And then your piles are everywhere.
All right, next,
we're gonna head to the desk.
So let's go over.
Next is the desk and office setup.
Oh, you guys, I mean that, oh.
(Clea laughs)
The old desk setup.
I know.
I mean, my desk is, well, it's ridiculous.
(Clea and Joanna laugh)
So I'm very curious about this.
Okay, okay.
Because I got no desk game.
The best, one of the best things you can do is
to get just a portable drawer.
A file folder.
Thank you, thank you.
File box.
Yep.
And you wanna just file
away important documents into one file.
And then you can put, if we have receipts
or something laying around,
you can put those in a different file.
And then you just wanna label each file
so that when you go to look for something,
it's so easy and right there.
And again, a color-coded system can be really helpful.
You can have like your auto, your home, your work,
whatever it may be.
Right, and that way you're not just overwhelmed with piles
again, it's the piles that are the problems.
And let me ask you a question,
'cause I immediately go to,
funny enough, we have an example right here.
Now this, just tell me what I should do in this scenario.
And you might tell me this isn't for that.
What if you have different size papers?
Sure, okay, well this in particular
is more sentimental items.
These are special things
like cards people have made for you,
things that you really wanna hold onto.
Kids art, this is a great option.
Shoe boxes.
Well, opaque boxes.
That's right.
You want to hold onto them.
But what we call a file box is for touch access,
things that you need to get to, bills, a form,
things you actually need to be filing and looking up.
Sentimental items are things that, on a rainy day,
maybe you wanna take the box down
and go through it and look at it.
Right, pictures, special memories.
That way they're nice and tidy.
Pretty.
I know.
And then you can go in them on a rainy day
and look at all the beautiful artwork
that your kids or friends made.
And set them up for your kids, too.
(audience applauds)
So another thing that tends
to really perplex people these days is what to do
with all of your cords and cables.
Charging stations are a big one.
This is a cord wrap.
It's amazing. It's magical.
And honestly, all you do at the end of the day is you just,
you twist it, and then you keep all of your cables together
without making a giant mess.
And it's a little gift for you
when you're looking to charge anything.
And another thing you can do if you want, for instance,
if you wanna actually set up a docking station,
you can use a bin with a handle, have the cord plugged in,
and then all of your items can sit in a bin out of sight,
and it doesn't have to be taking over everywhere.
(upbeat music)